imagine this is our perception space and
we have two kinds of input data types
each neuron we add in the first layer
acts like a fold in this space and we
could keep going folding and unfolding
the paper to carve out regions to
separate these points this will take six
separate folds but now consider what
happens if we layer our folds that is we
don't unfold after each fold that ends
up carving the space in the exact same
way using three folds instead of six
this recursive power of folding shows
how we can get exponentially more
partitions using the same number of
neurons if we layer them practically
this means that neurons deep in a
network are not simple linear partitions
but are instead activated by a complex
pattern of linear
partitions